The final scenario all the way at
the other end of the spectrum is an All-In BI enterprise.
This is where your organization openly values data because of
the impact it can have on decision-making and invests in enterprise-level tools.
Either it has already created them or it's in the process of doing so.
Organizations can centralize power BI report development
into one or more dedicated teams,
or there can be distributed networks of those who use Power BI throughout the company.
Not unlike how almost everyone uses Excel from time to time,
even if they're not in accounting or finance,
your stakeholders could be anyone with a vested interest in reporting.
From a sales lead to the CEO,
your key allies will similarly run the gambit,
but the keys need still apply.
You need people to help you identify and access reliable data source,
and you need people to help you understand what the data is telling you,
and what it means for decision-making.